I took two weeks off for a total social media detox
and here's how I found myself really missing
over sharing my intrusive
inner monologue with strangers who didn't ask to hear it.
So from today, day 1,
I started writing my thoughts down.
Totally radical concept
and I believe it's got a soft J pronounced urinal and quite cathartic.
But please don't read my urinal.
I had zero minutes of screen time for the first 7 days.
And in the second week,
I thought I might treat myself and find a cute new show on Netflix.
It wasn't even a baby reindeer.
When that plan backfired, I thought I'd try some light reading instead
by revisiting my favorite treetop manual.
And this is gonna be right up there
with some of the best self help books of all time.
I don't know what it is. I just always find it
puts me in the right headspace
to enjoy the domestic bliss that comes with raising my three
fetal collaborations.
I like to gaslight myself into believing that I am actually Lobotomy
Barbie and everything is so much better when I do live laugh,
lobotomize. Then I got stuck into reading The Silent Patient
where I realized that becoming a mute
unhinged ward of the state sounded like a fucking dream vacation.
So I went ahead and caught Covid
and sadly during this
I Learned I can't keep my mouth shut for the life of me
and all this talk. Of covid in the bottom is
got me really in the mood for some homemade bread.
I think I glitched and got stuck in a loop
because I made about 10 batches of this for counter.
But I also think I might have finally nailed it.
And if you're wondering where the children are,
don't worry, I made sure to give them lots of special attention
and we played Monopoly Knockout for hours.
My youngest was sad cause she wanted to go first.
My older two boys were constantly rough housing
and I'll leave it up to you to decide
whether I'm protecting my children's privacy
or they're a figment of my imagination.
Don't worry darling. I did leave the house at one point
and that was for puppies and puppies only.
And I think we can all agree that
only leaving the house for puppies is a perfectly valid reason.
But I was there solely for therapy because unlike some men,
one bitch is enough for me.
I did some things to keep me mentally and physically supple,
mainly because I don't want my husband to run away with a sick,
although that would be pretty fucking strange
considering his secretary is actually his father.
But my mama raised me with the mantra
that low odds is not the same as no odds.
And I finished my yoga with my favourite pose,
corpse pose, which is another way of saying I'd lay down for 2 hours.